we begin the day remembering the life
and legacy of mikhail gorbachev the
soviet leader who helped end the cold
war gorbachev reportedly passed away
yesterday at the age of 91.
in the late 1980s gorbachev introduced
policies that encouraged openness and
reform inside the ussr
and he also forged warmer ties with the
west which ultimately brought down the
iron curtain ending the division of
europe and it also put germany on track
to reunification
as a political leader gorbachev wielded
unprecedented powers that set into
motion forces inside of his country
which he would soon no longer be able to
control
while he is often held as a hero here in
the west at home his name is associated
with the collapse of a mighty nation
his legacy is at best
a complicated one
we have this report
in michael gorbachev's first speech as
leader of the soviet union it was clear
he was a stark contrast to his
to live in peace predecessors freedom is
the most important basic right of each
individual
gorbachev wanted to change the soviet
union to bring it closer to the people
he promoted glasnost openness and
perestroika reforms two words that will
forever be associated with him
his new outlook was popular with many
his policies also applied to the
military despite the resistance of
soviet generals
i'm convinced that we will also have to
reform our military
we have far too many weapons
we have to seek dialogue with other
superpowers and reduce our arsenals to a
reasonable extent
[Applause]
as a result of that dialogue gorbachev
and u.s president reagan signed the
first of many disarmament treaties in
1987.
it was the beginning of the end of the
cold war
in october 1989 when he visited east
berlin for the gdr's 40th anniversary
celebrations
gorbachev urged eric honaker to
implement reforms
he warned the east german leader saying
life punishes those who come too late
a month after his visit the berlin wall
fell and with it the iron curtain that
had divided europe for decades
[Music]
it was gorbachev's reformist policies
that helped unleash a peaceful
revolution across eastern europe
[Music]
in 1990 gorbachev was awarded the nobel
peace prize for his key role in bringing
about a new peaceful world order
internationally he was highly regarded
but at home he was increasingly under
pressure the economic situation was dire
the soviet union on the verge of falling
apart
communist hardliners staged a coup
against gorbachev in august 1991.
at the end of that year mikhail
gorbachev announced his resignation and
the soviet union was dissolved with many
russians holding him responsible for its
demise
[Music]
well the passing of mikhail gorbachev
has triggered across the globe waves of
emotions and reflections and they all
speak to the impact that gorbachev and
his policies had far beyond the borders
of the former soviet union
joining me tonight to discuss the legacy
are two authorities on soviet and
russian history as well as foreign
policy angela stent she's the author of
putin's world
russia against the west and with the
rest
professor stint is a senior fellow at
the brookings institution she joins me
tonight from washington and i'm also
happy to welcome to the program william
taubman
he is a pulitzer prize-winning author
his latest book is entitled gorbachev
his life and times and mr talbon is also
in the u.s capitol tonight to both of
you welcome to the program i'm glad that
you could take the time
with us this evening to talk about the
life and legacy of mikhail gorbachev
his death became known public knowledge
about 24 hours ago the west
has been emoting ever since about a
great statesman
inside russia
we've had a telegram from the kremlin
sent to the family and that's about it
we in the west it seems wish that we had
had more gorbachev and in the kremlin
you get the sense that they are wishing
that they had never had any gorbachev
professor stint let me start with you um
what do you say to that is that how the
the dividing lines are tonight
well they currently are certainly like
that
in western europe and the united states
we think gorbachev is a great statesman
who ended the cold war allowed germany
to unify
peacefully and really liberated millions
of people inside the soviet union
freeing political prisoners and then in
eastern europe who had been part of the
soviet bloc um that's not how he's seen
clearly either in the kremlin or among
many russians uh who
bemoan the fall of the soviet union
after all putin himself has said that
the collapse of the soviet union was the
greatest geopolitical catastrophe of the
20th century because it left millions of
russians outside of russia and he's
right now trying to remedy it and really
he has systematically gone about
reversing many of the reforms that
gorbachev himself did
yeah we're going to talk about that in
just a moment mr talbon let me
ask you about the notion of gorbachev
inside russia you have written that
gorbachev was
too decent
to be the leader of his
country why do you think that is
well just look at his predecessors uh
soviet leaders like lenin stalin
they were
all too
ready to shed blood in the case of
stalin especially on a mammoth scale
to attain their aims gorbachev was
reluctant to use force and violence
gorbachev
was very optimistic about the
possibilities of people coming to
govern themselves in a democracy
gorbachev trusted reagan thatcher
mitterrand coal to work with him to end
the cold war
these qualities of optimism of trust
of revulsion against force and violence
these
turned out to
not be
sufficiently
suitable to a country in which had
experienced so much force and violence
so much
totalitarianism
i got to know him fairly well when i was
interviewing him for the book and in
person he struck us too as a as a decent
man warm informal
uh natural with a sense of humor
uh i often wondered how the hell he had
managed to
defeat his rivals to become the leader
of this country and then how he dared to
think that he could get away with
transforming it and the world in the
ways that he dreamed he could well mr
talbot
that's that's a good point you make
gorbachev he set into motion forces that
he would later not be able to steer or
control at all i mean
and we have to remember he was a
communist leader who wanted reform but
there was no guidebook for him to turn a
command economy into something that
resembled a market economy i'm wondering
if if you think did he push forward with
these reforms somewhat blindly and
with a considerable degree of naivete
well i would say yes he was naive and
even utopian in a sense that he tried to
do
what turned out to be impossible you can
make a pretty good case
that his whole project was doomed from
the start by
russia what it was by its own history by
the forces who remained from the soviet
totalitarianism
who were allied in a raid against him
but nonetheless he tried
and in that sense you know one has to
respect him admire him
and almost wish for more
leaders in other countries who would
dare to try
and professor stint
gorbachev of course um was not he wasn't
a simple man he was complex he was
complicated he was a complex and
complicated
russian
he considered the annexation of crimea
to be correct
in 2014
but he was quoted as saying that war
with ukraine would never happen he said
also even if you can't prove it
scientifically
the russians and the ukrainians they
belong
together
what picture does that paint then of
gorbachev well i think his attitudes
were very much those of soviet people
and many russians today uh after all
ukraine you know was part of the soviet
union um ukraine and russia have a
history a very complicated history that
goes back centuries and so
most russians found it very hard when
the soviet union collapsed to accept
that ukrainians were a separate nation
uh and had the right to a separate state
so i i think it's uh unremarkable that
he said those things but we should also
remember that he unleashed a process
and and i think when gorbachev came to
the united states in the early 90s and
he was speaking at the library of
congress somebody asked him what was
your biggest mistake and he said in an
understatement i underestimated the
nationalities question so i think like
many soviet uh leaders and soviet
citizens he didn't realize how much the
non-russian nationalities actually
wanted their own independence and as
soon as he opened up glasnost and people
were able to discuss these issues their
desire for freedom and independence
became stronger but he did unleash a
process where the ukrainians were while
the soviet union still existed were able
to elect their own leader within the
soviet union and so again these were
processes that he unleashed that he
didn't fully understand and that he
didn't intend to do at the beginning he
did not intend to see the destruction of
the soviet union but we have to remember
that he in the end did nothing to stop
it um and i think that again he's unlike
most russian leaders that he voluntarily
stepped back admittedly under pressure
from boris yeltsin and the ukrainian and
bella russian leaders but he didn't
fight to stay in power he didn't have
the army come and support him so um
i think we shouldn't criticize him too
much for what he said about ukraine
because for a man of his generation um
it's not surprising professor i want to
pick up on the on the putin factor here
you along with fiona hill um
wrote an article in foreign affairs
recently and the title is the world
putin wants
has
putin succeeded already in dismantling
everything that gorbachev was able to
achieve
inside russia in terms of greater
openness
and
extending freedom such as freedom of
expression freedom of the press
well russia is a far more oppressive
place now than it was uh the soviet
union was under gorbachev um and it
resembles to some extent what life was
like under the region of p in the
brethren period the only difference is
that russians can still with greater
difficulty leave russia he really has uh
dismantled most of it and primarily he
is hell-bent on subjugating ukraine on
reabsorbing ukraine into russia into
some kind of a slavic federation so he
is deliberately reversing
in essence the collapse of the soviet
union he said that the collapse of the
soviet union was the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe and he's
determined to reverse that but whether
he can do it i don't know but it's
certainly the direct opposite of
everything that gorbachev said in motion
and mr chapman do you see then the the
invasion of ukraine is is this
vladimir putin's
remedy to
the disaster that occurred
during gorbachev's watch
well putin obviously thinks so i i don't
think so myself because it's hard to
characterize a bloodbath uh with all
kinds of horrendous consequences
as a remedy
but he cert this is putin's way of
saying
uh without saying it that gorbachev was
responsible for allowing the soviet
union to fall apart and and that falling
apart included as angela just said
the the
attempt
successful in the end by so many of
those soviet republics to break away and
become independent and sovereign and try
to determine their own future
i'd like to get
both of you to give me your opinions on
on this assessment there are some
americans who may be tempted to call
mikhail gorbachev the soviet jimmy
carter
a leader a man who had the best
intentions
for his country and his people but whose
policies left voters feeling worse not
better mr tubman what do you say
was he was he the soviet jimmy carter at
the end of the day
i'm sorry were you asking me yes yes
yes
well
i'm rolling that around in my head
as i said there was a certain naivete to
gorbachev there was a certain utopianism
but
on the other hand gorbachev was tough
and canny and his ability
working within the still
confines of the soviet system to get
commerce communist hardliners to give up
their power
until they changed their mind and tried
to get his
uh uh get him to give up his was really
quite extraordinary when you go back to
1985
when he took over
and assumed the leadership of a
politburo that included
the brezhnev cohorts cohorts and lackeys
it's really remarkable what he was able
to do in fact the irony i think
is that he proved to be a more
successful
ruthless manipulator of the old levers
of the old soviet system
than a uh
a sort of entrepreneur of democracy he
was better at forcing out germico
the kremlin
than in
mobilizing electoral forces to back his
policies once he had opened up
the system to free
voting
elections and
created a genuinely
functioning parliament
and professor
what's your take on this because
after he left politics gorbachev you
know he set up this institute that was
trying to help civil society in russia i
mean there are analogies to what we've
seen
with former president jimmy carter but
other u.s presidents
do you see americans maybe being able to
draw this comparison
well with all due respect to president
carter um i think what president uh
leader gorbachev did um was far more
consequential because even though he
made mistakes uh he clearly vacillated
between economic reform and then going
back to the centrally planned system um
he he was a very good tactician but in
the end i think he didn't have a very
good strategy given all of that
freeing the russian people giving them a
greater liberty and freedom of
expression that outlasted him it
certainly lasted into the 90s we can
discuss what else happened in the 90s
but this this feeling of greater
empowerment that he gave russians that
outlasted him this is something now
obviously that the putin regime is
trying to crush and to try and reverse
but even younger people today and today
you can follow the tweets that alexey
navalny the opposition leader who is in
solitary confinement in prison but
somehow gets the tweets out through his
lawyers um
praising gorbachev not only for these
freedoms but because he's an example of
a leader who wasn't corrupt he could
have accumulated wealth and all the
finer things of life and he didn't so i
think he set an example there which even
though uh it's very difficult to follow
it at the moment in russia is something
that has outlasted him and that even
younger people understand and professor
stan i'd like maybe if you could help me
here and try to connect the legacy of
gorbachev to the situation we see in
modern day america tomorrow evening u.s
president biden plans to speak to the
american people reportedly
about the battle for the soul of the
country he's concerned about that
is there a connection to the death of
gorbachev gorbachev represented ideas
that made
our current world order possible he has
now passed away
and
do you do a lot of americans feel that
the world that as we know it also seems
to be slipping away as well
well certainly gorbachev promoted
successfully greater democracy uh within
the soviet union and what we see today
in the united states clearly is an
erosion of democracy um and and and
if not half of the country significant
part of the country no longer believing
in normal democratic norms and the rule
of law so i think it's a very it's a
very serious situation um and i think uh
it behooves us to look at other
countries
where where these freedoms and the rule
of law no longer exist and remind
ourselves that if we go down that path
then in fact that will be the end of
this democratic experiment in america
we've got two more minutes i've got a
final question to you both mr chapman
i'll start with you gorbachev and putin
never criticized each other
publicly at least not directly putin did
not praise gorbachev today
but he also did not cast him in a
negative light even in that telegram
that was sent to the gorbachev family
does gorbachev in your opinion does his
legacy does it present
any type of threat to putin more
in depth than gorbachev did in life
well you know among the apparently tens
of thousands maybe hundreds of thousands
of russians who have immigrated fled
from putin's russia after the war and
ukraine began
at least one person was telling me the
other day
that there are a lot of russians who
believe another perestroika
is necessary
now i can readily believe that among
those who have fled from putin's russia
i guess the question is are there among
those who have not fled especially the
younger generation
is is it dawning on them that the kind
of reforms that
that gorbachev favored the peristroika
uh is again
something that they hope to see
happening in russia i guess i'm
skeptical as to how wide that sentiment
is after all these years in which
russians have accustomed themselves to
uh despising russia gorbachev
unfortunately we're out of time but i
want to thank both of you angela stint
senior fellow at the brookings
institution and william taubman pulitzer
prize-winning author to both of you we
appreciate your time and your insights
an excellent discussion helping us
understand the legacy of mikhail
gorbachev thank you
thank you
you